it's great to have back on the program
today vincent racinello who's a virology
professor at columbia university and
also host of this week in virology uh
great to have you back i really
appreciate it oh great to be here so i i
mean i guess we have to start with
omicron and uh the
if whatever prediction you want on
omicron you can find it which is this is
the beginning of something that's going
to get much worse this is the beginning
of the end of the pandemic and
everything in in between
what do we know now
about
the level of transmissibility of omicron
in terms of its r value as well as how
much more or less likely it is to cause
hospitalization
determining transmissibility is very
difficult so getting of our value
especially this far into an epidemic is
very hard
but i like to look at what we call
secondary attack rates
which are calculated
in closed situation like a household yes
where you can know that this person was
infected and then within a certain
amount of time these other people got
infected and it's not easy to do that
but recently a pre-print came out of
denmark where they did it and the beauty
of the study was it was just when they
were transitioning from delta to omicron
so you had
households that were either an omicron
household or a delta household it was
right perfect perfect and they had good
numbers and they have a terrific
medical records registry there so they
could get all the information and what
was very clear
is that omicron has a higher secondary
attack rate than delta so it's
transmitting better in the household
situation
but that appears to be entirely due to
the fact that omicron is evading
antibodies
because as you know it has many changes
in the spike protein more than any other
variant and if you take sierra from
people who have been vaccinated or
recovered from infection it doesn't
block infection with omicron as well as
say with delta and so
the danish
scientists concluded that this increased
ability of mammogram to transmit say
within households is entirely due to
immune evasion and not to an inherent
increased
transmissibility of the virus so we
imagine that there are some properties
of viruses that can make them transmit
better maybe they reproduce better
they're more stable in droplets that
come out of your respiratory tract but
that's not the case with omicron it
really is evading
antibodies and that's why it's spreading
now the other part of your question how
about disease right now with first
reports out of south africa suggested
it might be milder and people started to
call it an army cold which is not really
right my colleague daniel griffin an
infectious disease doctor said that's
not right because he's seen plenty of
very sick people
infected with omicron and especially
unvaccinated people so in the
unvaccinated omicron can be just as
severe as delta and previous variants
but the south african study was kind of
complicated because a lot of the people
in their study were vaccinated and a lot
of them were younger and a lot of them
didn't have comorbidities and so that
all biases it to be milder so you know
making conclusions very quickly about
how severe infections are it's very
difficult so i would say at this point
we know that omicron can evade immunity
and that's why it moves through a
population well
it can infect vaccinated people just
like delta could but in a vaccinated
person the disease is much milder than
an unvaccinated person with there's so
many things that we could go off to
from there just a couple so if we look
at the uk as an example a lay person
might look at cases and deaths and of
course at this point we know that not
nearly all of the infections are being
captured as a case which depends on a
test but putting that aside for a moment
it looked like during the omicron wave
cases went up about 6x in the uk
uh known cases whereas deaths went up
somewhere between 80 and 100 percent or
so
when you see that it suggests that it is
in some way
less likely to kill people and that's uk
not south africa but is are those two
numbers alone not enough to really tell
us that well the problem is that a lot
of the people are
vaccinated and that if you stratify the
data yes vaccinated versus unvaccinated
make sure you control for age and
comorbidities which is not easy to do
true uh then
you find that in it's milder in
vaccinated people but so is delta and so
are all the other variants but the fact
is that vaccination works
it prevents you from getting severe
disease and now part of the issue is
with omicron it came at about the
holiday season right when everyone is
traveling and getting together plus we
are now getting together way more than
we ever did since the beginning of the
pandemic because people are starting to
relax and all of this contributes so you
know movement of a virus has many
factors around it not just the virus not
just your immunity but how people behave
as well
the um wastewater data in some cities in
the united states
is showing just dramatic reductions in
the amount of of virus during this
omicron wave i think when i looked 10
days ago or so or maybe a week ago at
boston wastewater data it was down about
two-thirds even though cases are only
down about 10 percent which which you
know you would imagine that that would
be a cases would be a lagging indicator
to the wastewater
how important is the wastewater data
i'm not sure you can you can quantify
anything all you can say is we have this
virus here now so there may be a period
where you don't see a virus in
wastewater or the levels are very low
and then suddenly you get more positives
so that can inform you of an impending
epidemic but i would not make much of
the levels because you know this is this
is incidental virus that you're
swallowing it's passing out of your
gastrointestinal tract and going into
the sewer so
it's not really part of the infection
process
so so to ascribe any meaning to how much
is there remember it's we're doing pcr
to measure
viral rna in the water and as a recent
study out of switzerland just showed
there is very little correlation between
pcr levels and infectious virus so
i think you have to be you have to
realize the limitations of looking at
virus rna and wastewater that's fair
that's fair
last time you were on we talked a little
bit about the very top level
understanding that we have about viruses
over time
becoming less deadly and you gave us
many caveats when we talked about that
but it was this sort of general idea in
the last few weeks as the conversation
about what happens after omicron has
become a more and more relevant
conversation there have been a bunch of
different articles coming out claiming
to debunk that idea as a general
principle that really viruses become
more chaotic and that that could get you
a
milder disease but it might not and that
there are counter examples from history
can we now
because it seems more relevant than ever
talk a little more specifically about
this idea of what is likely to come next
after omicron
so the idea which we talked about last
time you know it's a it's a human idea
that viruses over time
tend to get less virulent but we're
talking about long long periods of time
we're not talking about two years here
ah so for example if a virus spilled and
remember all human viruses came from
some other animal at some point in time
let's say thousands of years ago tens of
thousands of years ago
measles virus fifteen thousand years ago
spilled over into people from cows right
and so initially it's probably quite
lethal because it's a new host we have
no immunity to the virus and it does
what soros cov2 does but over time
population immunity grows and that helps
you have more a milder disease when you
get infected now
there's also this hypothesis that maybe
the virus changes over time because
there's no point in killing your host or
making your host very sick
so random changes in the genome that
reduce
virulence may persist but i have to say
you know with the one exception that we
might have talked about last time using
viruses to kill rabbits in australia
there's no other evidence that
viruses tend to get less virulent over
time in their hosts it's just an
appealing hypothesis so the australian
situation they had brought in rabbits in
the 1800s for hunting purposes they
opened they multiplied like crazy there
were too many of them so they introduced
a virus to try and kill them and in the
first year 99 of their rabbits were
killed but then those those one percent
that survived were more resistant to the
virus and then the virus changed to be
less virulent as well so it's actually a
beautiful experiment that's consistent
with this idea but i must say there's no
other evidence for it and as you
mentioned as soon as omicron came out we
had these data from south africa
people were saying oh it's getting less
virulent but i i think it's far too
premature to say that because as we've
already talked about there are lots of
confounding factors there so what does
that do for the conversation about what
what is next and whether we are months
from shifting from the pandemic to the
endemic phase of this is it do can we
really say anything about that at this
point
well from the start we have thought that
as population immunity grew to this
virus we would have
less and less severe disease and we see
that in vaccinated people it supports
that even though we have many variants
emerging that can evade immunity to a
certain extent
the vaccines still work they protect you
from severe disease and hospitalization
really in the 90s percent still so
and we know from other coronaviruses the
common cold coronaviruses that infect
all of us every year
that widespread population immunity
probably associates with milder disease
and so that from the very start
led to this idea that over time as more
of the world became immune to a soros
cov2
we would have less and less severe
disease the virus would not necessarily
be changing with respect to virulence
but simply population immunity uh would
do that i really think that's what's
going to happen because we see the
vaccines working really well
despite the the energetic evolution of
the virus so i've always thought and
this was actually
an idea influenced by ralph barrick who
was a corota virologist for many years
he said
this will probably be a common cold
coronavirus who knows how long it will
take
and at that point we might not need to
vaccinate it against it any longer
we're not at that point yet though i
don't think we are because you know most
of the world is still not fully
vaccinated right right
there are some countries that have very
high rates of vaccination and they have
much less disease
as a consequence but there are other
countries like africa which is which are
barely vaccinated so we can't hope to
end a pandemic until we get
either a lot of people infected or
vaccinated i mean that's what's going to
happen now over the next few years
you're going to either get vaccinated or
you're going to get infected in both
cases you're going to get some kind of
immunity
there are a few countries at least a
couple the uk
australia that are pretty quickly going
in a direction of saying
uh we are we believe we are functioning
as though we are in the endemic phase we
are going to start removing restrictions
and kind of putting this at the
individual level to say if if if i have
a particular reason that i need to go
beyond what's required of me by by the
state i'm going to do it based on my
level of risk does that make any sense
to you at this point in time it does and
i've been thinking about this for now
many weeks because we it's very clear we
have multiple vaccines that work they
don't prevent infection which is normal
but they do prevent severe disease and
so in many countries like the uk and
israel and the u.s where we have plenty
of vaccine
we now have vaccines that can control
severe disease people who have decided
not to be vaccinated have made their
choice so i think the rest of the
population can now start to move on the
only problem
with that idea
is that if too many unvaccinated people
get infected as you know the healthcare
system gets overburdened yes and
that is a problem because they have
other issues to deal with they have
other health problems in patients to
deal with so we don't want hospitals
full of unvaccinated severely ill
covered patients that's why i think in
many places in the us we're still
masking even though we're all fully
vaccinated many of us are fully
vaccinated
there's no risk to us anymore of of
getting severely ill we are protecting
the unvaccinated the biggest and most
regular pushback that i hear when
anybody says what you just said is but
hold on a second even the people doing
everything correctly getting their three
doses and and etc
they are still at greater risk due to
the unvaccinated because of the ability
to spread the disease the counter that's
incr increasingly being placed upon us
is well hold on a second
with omicron it's not clear that the
vaccines prevent transmission they
prevent death they prevent serious
illness but but do they really prevent
transmission so it's really a two-part
question what about the people saying
even those who did the right things we
are still at risk because of everybody
else and number two what do we know
about the effect of the vaccine on
transmission right now
so the i feel i am not at risk from an
unvaccinated person okay because i am
triple vaccinated and if i get infected
which i likely will
i will have a mild disease right there's
a very good chance i have a mild disease
most of the severe disease in unvex and
vaccinated people
you know that 10 or so that that are in
people with comorbidities either they're
older or they're obese that's a big one
or diabetic or asthmatic
those are the people who get are most
likely to have severe disease even if
fully vaccinated of course we don't want
to forget the kids under five who can't
be vaccinated yet we still have to be
careful about them so i don't view
vaccinated people as the ones at risk
it's the unvaccinated people and they're
the ones that are going to cause
problems in the healthcare system
now with respect to transmission
there there was a wonderful pre-print
out of switzerland last week and this
complements other work that's that's
come out as well which clearly shows
that well first of all you can't measure
transmission by doing pcr
that is very clear in almost every study
that has looked at
shedding of a vaccinated person is wrong
because they're measuring pcr and that
does not correlate with infectious virus
shedding in the swiss study they showed
that a vaccinated person not only sheds
less infectious virus than an
unvaccinated person but does so for
fewer days after being infected okay and
so that has significant implications so
vaccination doesn't abolish shedding it
doesn't abolish transmission but it
knocks it so far down that it no longer
plays a role in driving uh the epidemic
so that that seems to then support those
who say
i'm vaccinated but the unvaccinated are
putting me at risk i know statistically
you still won't be seriously ill but a
lot of people have comorbidities in this
country it sounds like it's not wrong to
say even as a vaccinated person the
unvaccinated do put me at greater risk
no the
unvaccinated do not because you are not
going to get sick right if you're fully
vaccinated the likelihood you're going
to get severely ill is very low oh i see
so it's both it's both that
the by being by being unvaccinated you
are shedding more virus but by being
vaccinated you also are less likely to
actually get sick exactly okay you are
less likely to pass it on to someone
else as well so the more people we have
vaccinated the more likely we can stop
the transmission
uh very that's we we are going to link
to that uh pre-print from switzerland it
sounds like there's really a wealth of a
wealth wealth of data there we've been
speaking with vincent racinello virology
professor at columbia university and
make sure to check out this week in
virology always great having you on
thank you for having me david appreciate
it